They ask
me
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of patience,
patience
as we are going to learn and as we have
learned somewhat in this chapter
is far more and far more broad. It
stretches far beyond
merely
patience in one thing as opposed to
another or patience you know a lot of
times people will gauge patience
as only being patients
with regards to one or two things
right so if somebody is very slow to
anger for instance or if someone is
very quick to anger this is a part of
patience. This is not all of patience.
Patience is far more broad than that.
Kind of character. Often times
we kind of reduce good character
as just smiling. That's not good
character per se. That's a a very small
part of a much bigger thing that is good
character. Good good character
sometimes
it is part of good character not to
smile. It can be right. Good character
is that a person gets angry for the
sake of Allah. loves for the sake of
Allah. gives for the sake of Allah,
withholds for the sake of Allah, is
truthful, is courageous,
right? Is generous. This is all part of
character.
reducing these huge
broad terms to very small acts or
individual isolated things of that
makes it very superficial kind of like
worship which we've discussed before
say what is worship say well worship is
you know making salah and
fasting in Ramadan and reading the
Quran and you know that's pretty much
it. That is an incredibly simplistic
view of what worship is, right? Those
are just instances of worship. As a
matter of fact, the majority of a of a
man or woman's worship will not be in
those three things.
Worship is anything that pleases Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala. Anything that
pleases Allah. Telling the truth is
worship.
an individual
even a person's sleep, even a
person's diet can be worship. And so as
we'll learn, patience is far more broad
than one or two isolated acts.
patience is a very broad term that
has many aspects to it and for this
reason
he famously was quoted as saying that
patience is to a man's religion as one's
head is to his body.
Right? Patience is to a man's.
Religion as one's head is to his body.
Without a person's head, they have no
life even if the rest of the body is
there. Likewise is the issue of
patience.
We stopped at the 155th
verse of Bakari.
When he begins a chapter on a particular
topic, he will usually begin with a
verse of the Quran or verses of the
Quran. This will act as a prelude and
the basis upon which all the following
narrations will orbit and will
circle. And so, , the choices that he
makes for those verses, the select
verses that he opens a chapter with,
that he begins a chapter with, they are
extremely precise.
Each one of the verses that he chooses,
he has chosen it for its unique
contribution to the general meaning of
the chapter.
Yesterday we had kind of an
introduction into the verse number 155.
The verse has a lot of meanings which is
why today we will speak about one of
those meanings and tomorrow complete
those meanings inshallah and that is the
statement of Allah which translates to
and indeed verily we are going to test
you
test you all with a portion of fear and
hunger and a lack of wealth and bodies
and lives. lives and fruits and glad
tidings for the patient.
Starting with this statement of Allah,
we see this setup throughout the Quran,
the wow,
the lamb
followed by the what is referred to as
which is the response of the verily and
indeed and so forth. What does this
mean? Whenever we see this lamb
this wow after it is a lamb this is
called
this means that Allah is swearing
upon something.
It's as if Allah is saying, "I swear by
your Lord that verily indeed we are
going to test you all."
Now, if we understand just how concrete
this statement of Allah is, that there's
no escape. It is going to happen. If a
person is a believer in any way, even if
their belief is very very weak, they
must get a portion of testing that comes
with that. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam mentions
that
[Silence]
Wasam. He said sallallah.aii wasallam
that the most tribulated, the most
tried, the most tested men from amongst
mankind are the prophets,
followed by those who are most similar
to the prophets, followed by those most
similar to them. Each person will be
tested based on the strength of his
eman. If his eman is very strong, he
will have an additional portion of
tribulation.
And if his eman is lesser than that,
then his test will be proportionate to
his patience. We ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]